welcome back Gina Davis is in no hurry
to forgive a raging Bill Murray but can
we trust her what she condemns our
favorite Ghostbuster
actress Gina Davis says she's never
gotten over the way Bill Murray treated
her on the set of the 1990 movie Quick
Change
if you don't remember that film neither
does anyone else
I'm so hard it made Isis jealous
on Kara Swisher's podcast Davis said she
and Murray were about to shoot a scene
at a Manhattan intersection and she
wasn't sure if she was supposed to come
to set or not
when a pissed off Murray busted into a
trailer wearing a clown costume
I wonder if rage was coming out of his
eyeballs rage coming out of his eyeballs
and starts screaming at me and swearing
at me get the [ __ ] out there what the
[ __ ] what are you doing move move and it
got behind me and screamed in my ear
move faster move it and we're getting to
this intersection where there's hundreds
of people watching this and he keeps it
up and keeps it up until we used to
stand there and points to a mark on the
pavement and starts shooting start
shooting oh it sounds bad
but be happy it wasn't Alec Baldwin
to go to cat first because we work
together every day I listened to this
and I said there for the great that's me
I defend Bill Murray she's an idiot
right people have to understand that you
there's no reason to take your time in
television there's no reason because you
need to have and like he he was in a
clown costume cat he's in the middle of
the street and she's sitting in her
freaking trailer of course she's gonna
be pissed what say you cat you see me
every day acting the very same way no
you're you're worse am I worse yeah you
are worse because he went to go get her
himself I've done that you know you
don't oh yes I have it's my turn okay
thank you
what you do is you begin to yell at
everyone around you who is there why
isn't this person here yet why didn't
you tell them that they needed to be
here at this time to yell at those
people and then they run to go get the
person and when the person comes in then
you yell at them yes yes I double yelled
I yelled at one person you yell at least
seven yes I do I do but you have to
every single day but everybody should
welcome my yelling because it gets
everybody home sooner
that's my whole goal is so everybody can
get home to their loved ones their
little puppies
all right I got a Tyrus that's a nice
spin
with everyone and everything to do with
his barbecue yeah okay he gets hungry
and little Greg gets nasty he's like a
little he's like a little angry dog when
he doesn't get his meal on time so
that's what that's I admit it yeah but
also you have to be great I need to eat
but okay listen no no I'm I actually got
your back on this one okay because it's
open season on Bill Murray everyone's
trying to find something to go at him
but uh being in a few movies myself when
you get to your trailer you have what
the a little a little notebook that
shows when you're on the scene you're on
your lines for the day
and then you'll know and then you go to
makeup and you get done and certain
actors or actresses who think they're
more established than others take their
time so I you'll be on set and you're
waiting and waiting understand at least
three other people on the totem pole the
runner went to get her the production
assistant went to get her he's standing
in New York City in a clown outfit with
clown shoes on yes right okay for those
of you who have anyone who's ever
borrowed my shoes and tried to run
around with them not fun okay guaranteed
17. try it
it got to the point where the star of
the show
in clown shoes
went to your trailer yeah walked through
the set everything
and clown shoot
[Applause]
pounds on your door opens it up and
yells at you and the fact that her story
did not end with laughing hysterically
because Bill Murray dresses a clown is
cussing at you it's hilarious yeah
[Applause]
yeah and like she said it still bothers
her yeah like if that was what I had to
lie away about at night I'd be so
grateful it didn't it didn't bother her
that much there's no way uh because uh
she waited to say it for 30 something
years
um she was laughing when she was telling
the story yeah exactly but here's the
thing Gina Davis had a problem she
needed money she was going to write a
book she knew that nobody really cared
about the life of Gina Davis but she
knew they might care about Bill Murray
and so she came up probably with Bill
Murray with a pre-approved story that
really isn't that harsh you know I Bill
Murray was just going to say yeah I
yelled at her in a clown suit I mean but
this is her big trauma origin story
about how she became the has been she is
now I believe
I believe that in my life judging this I
must have 50 Gina Davis's lurking in my
background because I have given so much
to guests male and female about about
Lolly is it lollygags I hate the
lollygags listen you're gonna be 90 when
these people start writing their memoirs
you'll be flattered that they remember
you yes that's true
Fillmore is a notoriously horrible
person though to men and women that
um Richard Dreyfuss film What About Bob
with him right around the same time and
years ago he told the story about Bill
Murray got drunk at dinner
and came back and scr and was screaming
at him and said everyone hates you
you're tolerated that's a amazing it's
true
and but then through an ashtray at
Richard Dreyfuss about the size of well
that coffee table and he also threw a
producer in the lake on the same movie
and but this went on and on and on so
Gina Davis she went on this podcast with
that she shall remain nameless podcast
host who's odious because she tried to
make it a chip thing it's not a chip
thing Bill Murray he's hilarious but you
might not want to work with him but by
the way real quick Greg do you yell
about me behind my back uh
probably no he doesn't
she has the voodoo
[Laughter]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else